what advice would you give to uh
somebody thinking about doing a robotics
startup you mentioned cosmo somebody
that wanted to carry the cosmo flag
forward the anki flag forward
looking back at your experience
looking forward to the future that will
obviously have such robots what advice
would you give to that person yeah it
was the greatest experience ever and
it's like there's something you there
are things you learn navigating a
startup that you'll never like you you
it was very hard to encounter that in
like a typical kind of work environment
and um
and it's just it's it's wonderful you
got to be ready for it it's not as good
like you know the the glamour of a
startup there's just like just brutal
emotional swings up and down and so um
having co-founders actually helps a ton
like i would not cannot imagine doing it
solo but having at least somebody where
on your darkest days you can kind of
like really openly just like have that
conversation and you know lean on to
somebody that's that's in the thick of
it with you helps a lot what i would say
what was the nature of darkest days and
the emotional swings is it worried about
the funding is the worried about what
the any of your ideas
are any good or ever were good is it
like the self-doubt
uh is it like
facing new challenges that have nothing
to do with the technology like
organizational human resources that kind
of stuff what yeah you come from a world
in school where
you feel that uh you put in a lot of
effort and you'll get the right result
and input translates proportional to
output and
you know you need to solve the set or do
whatever and just kind of get it done
now phd tests out a little bit but at
the end of the day you put in the effort
you tend to like kind of come out with
your enough results to you kind of get a
phd
in the startup space like
you know like you could talk to 50
investors and they just don't see your
vision and it doesn't matter how hard
you kind of tried and pitched you could
uh work incredibly hard and you have a
manufacturing defect and if you don't
fix it you're gonna you're out of
business um you need to raise money by a
certain date and there's a you got to
have this milestone in order to like
have a good pitch and you do it you have
to have this talent and you just don't
have it inside the company or
um
you know you have to
get 200 people or however many people
kind of like along with you and kind of
buy in the journey um you're like
disagreeing with an investor and they're
your investors so it's just like you
know it's like you there's no walking
away from it right so um and it tends to
be like those things where you just kind
of get clobbered in so many different
ways that like things end up being
harder than you expect and it's like
such a gauntlet
but you learn so much in the process and
there's a lot of people that actually
end up rooting for you and helping you
like from the outside and you get good
great mentors and you like get find
fantastic people that step up in the
company and you have this like magical
period where everybody's like
it's life or death for the company but
like you're all fighting for the same
thing and it's the most satisfying kind
of journey ever um the things that make
it easier and that i would recommend is
like be really really thoughtful about
the
the application like there's a there's a
saying of like kind of you know team and
execution and market and like kind of
how important are each of those um and
oftentimes the market wins and you come
at it thinking that if you're smart
enough and you work hard enough and
you're like have the right talented team
and so forth like you'll always kind of
find a way through and um it's
surprising how much dynamics are driven
by the industry you're in and the timing
of you entering that industry um and so
just uh waymo is a great example of it
there is the i don't know if there'll
ever be another company or or suite of
companies that
has raised and continues to spend so
much money at such an early uh phase of
revenue generation and product and
productization um the you know from a p
l standpoint uh like it's it's a
anomaly like by any measure of any
industry that's ever existed um except
for maybe the us space program uh like
right uh like but
it's like uh
multiple trillion dollar opportunities
which is so unusual to find that size of
a market that
just the progress that shows the
de-risking of it you could apply
whatever discounts you want off that
trillion dollar market and it still
justifies the investment that is
happening because like being successful
in that space makes all the investments
feel trivial now by the same consequence
like
the size of the market the size of the
target audience the ability to capture
that market share how hard that's going
to be who the incumbent's like that's
probably one of the lessons i appreciate
like more than anything else where like
those things really really do matter
and um oftentimes can dominate the
quality of the team or execution because
if you miss the timing or you do it in
the wrong space you run into like the
institutional kind of headwinds of a
particular environment like let's say
you have the greatest idea in the world
but you barrel into healthcare but it
takes 10 years to innovate in healthcare
because of a lot of challenges right
like there's fundamental
uh laws of physics that you have to
think about and so um the combination of
like anki waymo kind of drives that
point home for me where you can do a ton
if you have the right market the right
opportunity the right way to explain it
and you show the progress in the right
sequence
it actually can really significantly
change the course of your
journey and startup how much of it is
understanding the market and how much of
it is creating a new market so how do
you think about
like space robotics is really
interesting you
you said exactly right the space of
applications is small
yeah
but you know relative to the cost
involved
so how much is like truly revolutionary
thinking
about like what is the application
and then
yeah but so creating something that
didn't exist it didn't really exist like
this is pretty obvious to me the whole
space of home robotics just everything
everything that cosmo did i guess you
could talk to it as a toy and people
will understand it picasso is much more
than a toy yeah
and
i don't think people fully understand
the value of that you have to create it
and the product will communicate it like
just like the iphone
nobody understood the value yeah of of
no keyboard and a a thing that's that
can do web browsing i don't think they
understand the value of that until you
create it yeah having a foot and a door
in an entry point still helps because at
the end of the day like an iphone
replaced your phone and so it had a
fundamental purpose and all these things
that it did better right sure and so
then you could do abc on top of it and
uh and then like you even remember the
early commercials where there's always
like one application of what he could do
and then you get a phone call right and
so that was intentionally sending the
message something familiar but then like
yes you can send a text message you can
listen to music you can surf the web
right and so
you know autonomous driving obviously
anchors on that as well you don't have
to explain to somebody the functionality
of an autonomous truck right like
there's nuances around it but the
functionality makes sense um
in the home
you have a fundamental advantage like we
always thought about this because it was
so painful to explain to people what our
products did and how like how to
communicate that super cleanly
especially when something was so
experiential and so you compare like
anki to nest
nest um
had some beautiful products
where they
started scaling and like actually found
like really great success and they had
like really clean and beautiful
marketing messaging because they
anchored on reinventing existing
categories where it was a smart
thermostat right and uh like and so you
you kind of are able to
um take what's familiar anchor that
understanding and then explain what's
what's better about it that's funny
you're right cosmo is like totally new
thing like what what is this thing
because we struggle we spent like a lot
of money on marketing we had a heart
like we fought we actually had far
greater efficiency on cosmo than um
anything else because we found a way to
capture the emotion in some little
shorts to kind of lean into the
personality in our marketing and it
became viral where like we had these
kind of videos that would like go and
get like hundreds of thousands of views
and like kind of like get spread and
sometimes millions of views and so um
but it was like really really hard um
and so
finding a way to kind of like anchor on
something that's familiar but then grow
into something that's not um is an
advantage but then again like you don't
have like there's successes otherwise
like ox had never had a comp right uh
you could argue that that's very novel
and very new and um
and there's a lot of other examples that
kind of created a
kind of a category out of like kiva
systems i mean they like came in and
they like
uh enterprise is a little easier because
if you can uh it's less susceptible to
this because if you can argue a clear
value proposition it's a more logical
conversation that you can have um with
customers it's not it's a little bit
less emotional and um kind of subjective
but
in the home you have to
yeah so like a home robot it's like what
does that mean yeah and so then you
really have to be crisp about the value
proposition and what like
really makes it worth it like and and we
by the way went to that same order we
almost like
we almost hit a wall coming out of 2013
where
we were so big on explaining why our
stuff was so high-tech and all the kind
of like great technology in it and how
cool it is and so forth um to having to
make a super hard pivot on why is it fun
and why do like does the random kind of
family of
four need this right like so
it's learnings but
that's that's the challenge and i think
like robotics tends to sometimes fall
into the new category problem but then
you got to be really crisp about why it
needs to exist well i think some of
robotics depending on the category
depending on the application
is a little bit of a marketing
this uh challenge and i don't mean
i mean
it's it's the kind of marketing that
waymo's doing that tesla is doing is
like
showing off incredible
engineering incredible technology
but convincing like you said family of
four
this this will this is like this is
transformative for your life this is
this is this is fun this is the don't
care about tech isn't your thing they
don't they really don't like they need
to know why they want it so some of that
is just marketing yeah that's why like
roomba like um yes they didn't you know
like
go and you know have this like
you know huge huge con you know ramp
into like the entirety of like kind of
air robotics and so forth but like they
built a really great business and um uh
in a vacuum cleaner world and like
everybody understands what a vacuum
cleaner is um most people are annoyed by
doing it um and now you have one that
like kind of does it itself
uh yeah in various degrees of quality
but that is so compelling that like it's
easier to understand and like
and they had a very kind of and i think
they have like 15 of the vacuum cleaner
market so it's like pretty successful
you